we're live hey good afternoon everybody
welcome back to cs109 how are you guys
doing today
oh fantastic I love to hear that I hope
you guys are having a splendid Friday
and you're looking forward to a great
weekend
everything okay
uh we're waiting for the screen to pop
up oh
it's probably much easier for the screen
to pop up if the HDMI is plugged in
I believe that
and there we have it okay thank you very
much wonderful wonderful people from
sapd
okay a couple quick announcements before
get started
um problem set one has its due date
today though there is a grace period so
if you are still making some small
tweaks that's okay problem set two
though will go out today so if you're
still working on problem set one it'll
be you know have less time to work on
this new problem set that's just gone
out uh and then happy Friday I'll tell
you a quick story and then for those of
you who went to python review session
one there's now python review session
two and that will be on Zoom after class
and also will be recorded in case you
can't make it
just want to talk really quickly about
the python or sorry about the problem
sets so problem set one was due here you
have a grace period that lasts until
tomorrow
if for some reason you really really
need an extension you can go all the way
until next Wednesday but after next
Wednesday we wouldn't accept anything
because we've started grading and then
you'll get your feedback next Friday so
one week from when you submit it to when
you get your feedback though of course
hopefully everyone's done by now because
then you can work on problem set too and
problem set do is due on the 17th and in
fact you basically know everything you
need to know to do problem set two if
you guys were really feeling it over
this weekend you could be done with
problem set too and really ahead of the
game for cs109 I know that will be a low
percentage of people but maybe that low
percentage of people could be you
and if it's not for you guys then you
know it would be like rocking and
rolling and just enjoying and learning
everything we can about probability
there's some really cool things in
problem set too one of my favorite
things that we've added is we're gonna
make you program this Bayes medical test
in every possible combination you have
to write a general solution to Bayes and
this is a relatively new thing in cs109
but the point is to make sure that you
really understand this most fundamental
concept that we've studied so far
the hardest thing in the problem or one
of the other ways that we're going to
push you is we're going to make you
think about Bayes theorem in a more
generalized world than we've seen in
lecture
in lecture we talk about Bayes theorem
where an event can happen or it can
happen but we're going to push you in
the problem set to think about well what
if there's many different possible
outcomes and here's one concrete example
imagine you're tracking an object and it
could be in any of these nine locations
I can give you a prior belief about
where the object is
I can give you
the probability of an observation that
is made given each location so I can say
you know here's the chance that your
object's in this location I can tell you
How likely is an observation like a
distance to a satellite tower or
something like that given each location
and then using Bayes theorem you can
update your belief about where the
object is
now
Bayes theorem
should just look like this you know
what's your belief of a new location
giving an observation you can just use
your regular base theorem the
interesting thing here is you know how
do you deal with this denominator when
your world isn't necessarily split into
location five or not location five
this denominator we've always expanded
using the law of total probability but I
just want to clue you guys into this
idea that that law of total probability
if your world is split into nine nice
locations you can write the law of total
probability like this for every location
what's the probability of the
observation and the location and that's
just another way to get your probability
of observation but just you know on this
problem set we're going to give you an
opportunity to extend Bayes theorem by
programming it for all situations and
also extend your knowledge of Base
theorem by thinking about it in a
context where there could be perhaps
nine outcomes instead of just two
yeah
okay
um
fantastic there's a cool problem on the
problem set that extends that bat genome
question we brought up yesterday or on
Wednesday's class it's going to require
that you actually write some python off
of the browser so if you don't already
have Visual Studio code or some other
programming environment you're going to
want to do that for problem set too
questions comments concerns about
logistics
I have a quick story for you I really
like this story it takes place in cs109
not too long ago
um and a student had come to my office
hours a few times it was a student who
had never seen any probability before
cs109 and all this was very new to the
student and
by the end of class
found this beautiful connection between
what we've been studying and her life so
she had been playing this game called
Ultimate Frisbee and you guys probably
have heard about it and did you guys
know that when you start a game of
Ultimate Frisbee there's this
interesting game that's played the two
captains go and they both flip a frisbee
and then one of the captains while it's
flipping claims heads or or evens or
odds if the if the person says evens if
they're either both up or both down then
that team starts and if it's odd that
means one's up and one's down
and we were thinking about this in cs109
and it turns out this game is not fair
and the person who figured out this
student you know went on to take this
concept got published in a magazine the
ultimate frisbee Magazine made a YouTube
video that became quite popular and I
think it tells the story of probability
is not just what we do the problem sets
it's something that lives all over and
if you can start to understand this
language you can better understand all
the different things that you might find
interesting in your world and so just by
taking 109 you know made some small
Improvement in the world of probability
uh and at the end of class just for some
excitement we're going to do a little
bit more gambling so just a little bit
of a heads up we'll talk more about that
when we get there
to do some review
we've talked about some of the most
foundational ideas and probability and
you guys have worked very very hard to
make sure that you understand each of
those Concepts and if you've made it to
this point you have this beautiful
Baseline and I just want to talk about
what's on that in that foundation so
we've got these core ideas and
probabilities just some definitional
understanding as a probability
we have
ways that we can think about conditional
probabilities
relations between conditional
probability is probably a band we have
relationship between conditional
probabilities and probabilities without
condition and we have relationships
between conditional probability and
conditional probably written the other
direction
and on Wednesdays we class we really
focused on understanding how you can do
probably if or
either in the case where you have
something that's mutually exclusive in
which case it's easy you just add or if
you don't have mutual exclusivity in
which case you can use inclusion
exclusion we also talked about how
probability of and is made a lot easier
by this other property called
Independence there are two different
properties
if you have events that are independent
probability of n becomes multiplication
and if you have events that are not
independent probably and
um is chain rule
now we have been implicitly using this
thing called de Morgan sometimes to go
between the probability of or and the
probability of N and de Morgan's kind of
says you know the probability
of e or F
if you take the not of that
it becomes 1 minus the probability of E
and F or sorry
the not of that becomes a probability
of e complement and F complement
people often find this a little bit
intuitive a lot of people have already
been using it in the problems that we've
talked about but if you find it hard to
go between ores and ends you probably
want to revisit de Morgan's which is
something you would have covered uh in
some of the set theory prior to cs109
to bring this all together I did want to
start practicing and in fact I was going
to have us
prep by thinking about that problem that
frisbee problem that I mentioned
do you know when you flip a frisbee it's
not equally likely to be heads or tails
that's what makes this so interesting so
I wanted you guys to imagine a world
where if you flip a frisbee we're going
to call the upside heads and the
downside Tails uh and I'm going to say
there's a 60 chance of getting that
upside
so if two frisbees are considered even
if either both of them are heads or both
of them are Tails what's the probability
that if you flip two frisbees they're
even and this is just a warm-up to bring
together the foundation we've talked
about talk to the person next to you see
if you can figure this out what's the
probability that they're both that the
two frisbees are even
okay
let's do this together
I'd say one of the Hidden skills in cs19
is can you take a word problem and can
you define events and once you define
events then can you express the problem
in terms of those events and this one I
think it's a lot easier if you can to
solve this problem if you can see that
there's two events whether or not you
get a heads on frisbee one and whether
or not you get ahead and frisbee too and
then you can recognize that this
question is asking either H1 and H2
or
H1 complement and H2 complement
I don't know do you guys find it a
little bit easier once you defined
events certainly this is a warm-up
problem but if you get to like meteor
problems defining events is absolutely
critical
now this or
would be super easy if a certain
property was helped what's that property
yeah and and mutual exclusively means
that they can't happen at the same time
are these two things mutually exclusive
ah fantastic why it was you can't both
get tails and both get heads that's
impossible uh these are two different
um of their mutually exclusive events
therefore
the probably we care about is just going
to be the sum of these two probabilities
now let's look at one of these probably
if H1 and H2 we're looking for an N so
what's the what's the property we care
about
Independence is the first frisbee
independent the second frisbee yeah we
think frisbees are independent which
means that this just becomes the
probability of H1 times the probability
of H2 and we know what the probability
H1 is we're given that 0.6 and we're
given that this is 0.6 for similar
reasons over here this is going to be
equal to 0.4 squared
great
actually just for fun this is like
really not
the sort of thing you'd have to invent
on the fly but just for a good time what
do you guys could you guys invent an
algorithm that would be fair given that
I'm going to give you frisbees they're
equally likely to be heads you just
don't know what the probability of heads
is
if I give you two frisbees they're
equally heads you don't know what
they're probably you don't you know like
maybe it's 0.6 maybe it's 0.7 it'll
probably have heads could you come up
with a game that would be fair so this
is an unfair way to start it turns out
if you plug in any number that's not 0.5
you're more likely to win if you call
evens can we come up with a game that's
better so that doesn't quick
clarifications before I throw you guys
to just think about this with the person
next to you
guys up for a Friday challenge
you don't have to but like see if you
can maybe maybe you'll come up with
something so
um you have these two frisbees some game
that would be actually Fair
and then I'll tell you about it in in
about a minute and a half so talk to the
person next to you
okay
maybe you came up with this
this is a cheeky problem but I find it
kind of like a fun algorithmic challenge
the answer there is an answer there
might be a more efficient algorithm and
if you guys came up with a more
affectionate efficient algorithm you
should certainly talk to me but here's a
rather inefficient algorithm that is
fair
Loop forever you're like this is
supposed to be done before you start the
game bear with me you're gonna flip both
Frisbees if they're odd that means one
was a heads and one was a Tails Whoever
has the heads wins
so if you think about it what's your
chance of winning well
in the case where they're odd
either you got a head tail or a tail
heads
and the probability of a head tail is p
times 1 minus p
and the probability tail head is p times
1 minus P so both these outcomes are
just as likely
now there is this problem problem where
like there's also the outcome of them
being even
but in that case if it's even you've
just repeat and no one's more likely
than the other person to win you could
get into a deep recursive proof If you
find this interesting and certainly as I
mentioned you know this could go on for
a long time you could flip they're both
the same you flip they're both the same
you flip they're both the same you flip
they're different and then it's over and
that seems like a pretty inefficient
algorithm though fair and if somebody
thinks of a more efficient one that'd be
so cool
what does Tails mean so that means one
Frisbee's up and one Frisbee's down
so you kind of keep going until the
frisbees are in different orientations
and then whoever had the heads in that
uh situation is the person who wins
and you're just as likely to have this
combination what you have heads the
other person has Tails as uh you have
tails the other person has heads
as I said not really reasonable for me
to make you invent algorithms on the
spot but just to show you what work in
this field could look like it's both
doing probability but sometimes
algorithms that uh work with
probabilities yes
with the heads out of the tube yes
exactly and if they're even what you do
start over yeah you just keep playing so
you just keep playing until you enter
the world where they're odds and in the
world where they're odds
um is just as likely that one person
uh wins as the other
what a wild time yeah
do you so the probability if you enter
the world where uh this is true so like
when you stop you know that you're in
either of these two conditions
and so you can imagine the chance that
one person wins is this probability
divided by the probability that you end
up in this world
um and then if you do love toad probably
just be this Plus
1 minus p
you'd end up with something like this
which would give you one-half so that's
like the chance that you end up in
this condition condition off the fact
that you've already entered the world
where uh they are odd
and these are the two ways you can get
odd
skills
exactly Tails heads or his tails
so you can think about this like what's
the probability person one wins
condition off getting odds
okay
great
and actually I wanted to do this because
I know the earlier you start problem set
2 is a great marker of you're going to
stay on track with this class and I
thought what if I just did one of the
problems in problem set two in class and
now you guys have all started problem
set too so who started problem set two
you can all raise your hand because
that's you just go right up this this is
one of your questions one of the warm-up
ones
okay
now there was this major key that I'd
like to restate it's worth restating
many times
you know conditional probability is a
new thing to get our heads around when
you condition on something you enter a
world where all the rules of probability
still hold so you know I guess you can
say for example if you consistently
condition on E
for example the Bayes theorem formula
would still exist in the world where e
is true so once e is happen Bayes
theorem still ha it still occurs you can
still talk about probably a given b as
the probability of B given a notice how
every formula here has a condition on E
in that world where e is happen rules of
probability still apply uh and yeah this
is now the Bayes theorem cute no okay
not cute
um and then you know I'm starting today
by pushing you guys a little bit uh and
then we'll go the second part of today
we'll just go into something very
definitional so bear with me for just a
moment
I did want to talk about these two
different concepts at the same time so
we've learned conditional probability
and we learned Independence but what
happens when you put those two things
together and it turns out quite a lot
happens when you put them together
let's go back to that cool program we
ran on Wednesday do you guys remember we
ran that program Wednesday we had all
these genes in this trait and after we
ran the program it said here's how we
think the genes influence the trait well
let's break this down a little bit
here's the input that the program had to
work with had examples of a hundred
thousand bats for every bat you knew
exactly the expression of the genes and
whether or not a trait was expressed
the
easiest thing you could do if you want
to try and understand how these genes
influences trait is to look for
Independence
Independence is something we learned
last time and here's how I did it the
first thing I did is I took every single
Gene and I checked does this Gene look
like it's independent of the trait
so to do that I would calculate what's
the probability of seeing the trait and
the Gene and that's just counting how
many times did I see these two things at
the same time divide my 100 000 bats and
that'll give me a probability
then I could say what's the probability
of the trait on its own what's the
probability gene on its own and I could
multiply those two things together do
you guys remember Independence if two
things are independent it should be the
case that the probability of each event
multiplied together should be the same
as the probability of the and really
quickly let's do this do you think trait
one is independent of G1
do you think it's independent Gene 2
do you think Gene three
a little controversial though they're
not exactly equal
but it's day
a thousand we haven't seen infinite bats
so like because we've only seen a
hundred thousand bats the fact that
these two numbers are so close I'm gonna
assume yeah they're looking pretty
independent
um how about the trait in gene four and
the trading Gene five
so the trait looks like it's independent
of Gene 3 and Gene four that tells us so
much it's pretty reasonable to assume
that knowing these genes doesn't change
your belief in whether or not the trait
will be expressed
so we kind of know that it's these genes
that are changing beliefs of whether or
not the trait is expressed we learn so
much by just looking at Independence and
for our my Advanced concept of the day I
want to think could we go a step further
and it turns out there is this thing a
step further it's a One Step Beyond what
we teach you in cs109 but it's something
that would be like one of the first
Concepts you learn if you took 228 or
one of the more advanced classes
is this idea of conditional dependence
and I want you to know it exists even if
you're not going to go so deep into it
in 109.
conditional Independence says
can we look for Independence
relationships in the case where I
condition on another event
so here I'm going to condition on I'm
going to tell you what G2 is that G2 is
expressed if I tell you that G2 is
expressed
then I can calculate the probability of
T and G5 in the world where G2 is
expressed and I calculated probably G in
the world where Jeep choose expressed I
can talk about the probability of G5 in
the world where G2 is expressed you know
to do this math computation is very easy
I just take my hundred thousand examples
and I only look at all the ones that are
consistent with G2 being expressed so
maybe there's only like 20 000 examples
where G2 is expressed and I'm only
looking at those 20 000. then I can say
what's the probability of T in those 20
000 what's the probably G5 in the 20 000
and what's probably T and G5
do you guys see how condition on G2 T
looks like it's independent of G5
was T independent of G5 before
no a beautiful thing sometimes happens
when you condition on an event it can
change Independence relationships
so in the world where I tell you what G2
is
it can now become the case that t and G5
are independent of one another
that's not the case if I didn't tell you
what G2 was and some of you are like
what how can this possibly be
there's a few causal structures in the
world that lead to exactly this and
here's one of them
G5 doesn't affect the trait directly G5
makes it more likely for G2 to be
expressed and G2 is what influences the
trait
so if I tell you whether or not G2 is
expressed
G5 is not giving me any more information
because G5 only changes my belief that
G2 is expressed
so g5's causal mechanism is by making
this more likely which makes T more
likely we're not going to go into the
depth of all the different causal
structures and probability you need to
build a bigger Foundation before we go
there but I did want to just bring into
light what happens when we mix causality
and or sorry conditioning and
Independence
technically conditional Independence
looks like this if you condition on some
event consistently
e and f look conditionally independent
if probably both of them happening in
the world where G's happen is equal to
probably e happening
condition on G times the probability of
f happening can you send G that's
exactly what we observed before uh it is
equivalent to this just like
independence of E and F is similarly
stated as probably of e given f equals
probability of E
and that's conditional Independence and
it looks just like the law of
Independence it's just that the
relationship might not be the same
between conditional Independence and
Independence a question so if you have
some condition that's applying to pretty
much that kind of hurt me is throughout
your own problem and you're essentially
in the world that condition you can
essentially like cancel out the
condition and have things to work out
oh all the laws of probability would
work yeah so so one way that we
sometimes Express this notationally just
to restate your question because it was
a good question
if there is a world G that permeates
your whole problem
sometimes we don't write down
conditioned on G and let me give you an
example I roll my dice
there's a whole bunch of things that
have happened in this universe before
the dice was roll you know it's like
what's the chance of me getting a two
conditioned on I had a big lunch today
and there's all these things that are
true the laws of probability still whole
even though I've had a big lunch today
but you know if if that event just
permeates the whole problem maybe you
don't have to write it
um yeah
sometimes these conditionings permeate
the whole problem you don't need to be
explicit about it and sometimes you have
to be explicit because they matter
Yeah question is this guaranteed
it regularly
that's such a good
question I want everyone to hear that
question I want you guys all to be
wondering
about that question
if two things are conditionally
independent does it tell you anything
about whether or not they're independent
when you're not conditioning on G this
is the most bizarre thing no they're
totally different things things can be
independent and then when you condition
on G they can look dependent again
things can be totally dependent but then
when you condition on some other event
they can start to look independent it's
because causality is such a crazy thing
but there is one major key
is just that Independence relationships
can change with conditioning the laws of
probabilities still hold when your
condition is just this property might
change between two events
let me give you an example that explains
why this is so useful if I may uh it
comes from Netflix so your question was
like what's why is uh conditional
Independence so useful and it turns out
it is a powerful thing to know that's
why I want to bring it to your attention
now
so we talked a little bit about the
probability that somebody likes this
movie a lot I like called life is
beautiful and we said you could
calculate the problem if somebody likes
this movie just by counting in the
Netflix data set you have Netflix has a
billion users and if a hundred thousand
watch this movie you can say that
probably somebody watches this movie is
100 000 over a billion
there's better numbers
now if you cared about a conditional
probability like the somebody probably
that somebody watches this movie
condition on the fact that they watch
another movie you could use the
definition of conditional probability
and that would when you reduce it come
out to
figure out how many people watch the
movie F and figure out what subset of
them watch both movies
and if you look at that ratio that would
give you your conditional probability
okay probabilities with data exciting
times you'll get to try this in problem
set two
but what if you condition on more than
one movie what if there was say four
movies or three movies that you're
conditioning on like you want to figure
out what's the probability that somebody
watches life is beautiful but you want
to condition on whether or not they've
watched Nairobi Half-Life Coda and three
idiots because Netflix is probably using
a lot of information to update its
belief on whether or not you'd watch a
movie like life is beautiful
there's a little bit of a problem
first of all do you think E4 is
independent of E1 E2 E3
I see some shaking heads that means no
to me and the reason I think no is a
very good answer to this is knowing
these three should change my belief
about E4
if somebody tells me that a user likes
or watched this movie in this movie in
this movie my belief is going to
increase that they've watched movie for
so there's reason to believe that
they're not independent
and because they're not independent it
is not true that you can just summarize
probably of E4 with ignoring E1 E2 E3
you actually have to think about this
using full conditional probability
okay so here's what you would do
you'd figure out what's the probability
that somebody watches all four movies
divided by probably that they watch
these three that's the definition of
conditional probability we can use it
right here fantastic uh problems gonna
come up though
hmm
this is my problem my problem is
let's say I want a condition on somebody
watching 30 movies
I have a counting problem for you let's
say there's 13 000 titles on Netflix
a user watches 30 random titles
e is the event that they specifically
watched the four I care about so
everybody watches 30 movies how many
people actually watch the exact four I
care about
and that's something we can calculate
using calc probability so a little
accounting problem for you guys
something to talk about with the person
next to you should use probably equally
likely outcomes how would you define
your event space your sample space and
then we can come up with this small
small probability
okay we'll go back to talking about this
but
I wanted to take a moment and see if
somebody could help me out with the
sample space see if we can get on the
same page with that
but what's the sample space that you
guys use we got 13 000 shoes here so 13
000 choose Thirty
every outcome here is a choice of 30
movies for uh for out of the 13 000
movies that are possible and we're gonna
say each of those outcomes is equally
likely because every movie is just as
likely as the other ones
these 30 movies don't necessarily
contain the four we care about how many
ways can we get exactly before we care
about that's the event space okay take
30 more seconds think about a little bit
more and then we will come up with the
answer together
okay
I have a two-step procedure for you guys
every single outcome here
includes all the ways you could choose
30 movies but I want to find the subset
of outcomes where they definitely have
those four I care about so here's a
two-step process for constructing an
outcome that has the four I care about
first put the four you care about into
the set we've Chosen and next choose 26
other movies from the 12 996 remaining
so this will give you the probability of
seeing exactly the four movies you care
about
and unfortunately if you were to bring
this to a calculator the probability of
somebody watching exactly those four
movies becomes incredibly small 10 to
the negative 11th now I assume that
people are equally likely to watch
movies and we know people have a little
bit more pattern to that
but this does present a problem for us
if you're conditioning on a whole bunch
of movies
you could very quickly enter the space
where you need to do a probability of an
event that looks pretty rare
Netflix has this really brilliant way of
leveraging conditional Independence to
make this calculation a lot easier
what they do is they say there is
another variable there's another event
and that event is this user liking
foreign emotional comedies
and they say it's this event that's
really governing whether or not people
like these four movies and then they
make an assumption it's a wrong
assumption but it's a very very helpful
assumption they say
the probability that you like this movie
is conditionally dependent of you liking
this other movie If I tell you that you
like foreign emotional dramas the
information is all coming through
whether or not you have this preference
and once I know if you have that
preference then whether or not you like
these movies start to look independent
they make this crazy in conditional
Independence assumption and once you
make this crazy Independence assumption
then the problem of E4 given all of
these things and also given K1 is equal
to the probability of E4 given K1 their
job has become much easier they just
have to infer whether or not you like
this idea of a film
and then they're going to base their
belief of whether or not you like a
particular movie within that genre on
that other event that they defined
super advanced stuff but I just kind of
want to tease you as to where this stuff
goes and to give you a little bit of a a
further explanation of why I think this
stuff is cool
conditional Independence makes
practical decomposing hard probability
questions
um it is true somebody said if two
things are dependent they might not be
dependent when you condition two things
are independent they might not be
independent when you condition
and this idea of putting together
conditioning Independence Judea Pearl
who won the 2011 Turing award said
exploiting conditional dependence to
generate fast probably probabilistic
computations is one of the main
contributions CS has made to probability
Theory
so conditional Independence is just like
Independence it's just in the world
where you condition on something and the
only gotcha is that Independence and
conditional Independence aren't
necessarily the same thing you know when
you condition on events that
relationship can change uh and then this
fact that you can use Independence in
the conditional world can make some
computations way way easier so hopefully
at this point I've motivated you're like
okay I appreciate conditional
Independence isn't just two random
combinations ideas uh is something that
might be worth feeling more comfortable
with
okay so that was my Advance that's one
of the more advanced things that I'll
talk about today I'm going to give you
guys a pedagogical pause quite early and
then we're going to go to our next cs109
episode see if you can summarize what
we've talked about today before we learn
about our next concept we're going to
learn about random variables what a good
time so take two minutes and then we
will continue our journey
okay
let's bring it back together and
I just want to point out a cool thing
look I know I've thrown so much at you I
Gave You Like Love told prob that I gave
you Bay is theorem I gave you the
definition of conditional Independence
we talked about independence and mutual
exclusivity so you probably or probably
and and that's a whole bunch but what
you guys have done now
is you've come to this really important
place in probability understanding you
have touched what I would call Core
probability you're at this interesting
part in cs109 where you have seen all
the fundamental pieces
and now we're just going to start using
those fundamental pieces to do ever more
interesting things the first interesting
thing we're going to do is we're going
to start defining families of patterns
with these core principles that we're
going to call random variables and once
you understand random variables that's
going to be our basis for AI you guys
have made a lot of progress I hope you
feel good I know it's been confusing for
a lot of people because it's a hard
thing to get your head around but good
on you for putting in all that hard work
to get here
the next cs109 episode is about random
variables and this is not going to be as
conceptually intense as thinking about
conditional Independence
it is instead just going to be new
terminology this is like the chat that
us probability experts use you're going
to be learning a new lexicon for talking
about things you already know
I want to set out a couple learning
goals for today by the end of today I
want you to be able to define a random
variable I want you to be able to use
and produce this thing we call a
probability Mass function and I want you
to be able to calculate expectation this
is a pretty reasonable set of things
that we're going to be able to do in the
next 40 minutes
I'm going to start by introducing to
this idea of random variables by going
back to the days of defining variables
in code and this is what it looks like
to Define variable in C plus plus or
Java and when you define a variable in
code what a powerful idea imagine you're
coding life before you have variables
and your coding life after you have
variables you know technically you could
probably do a lot of those programs
without any variables but they'd just be
very very messy actually no not possible
a variable in code what does it have it
has a type you know maybe it's integer
maybe it's a Boolean has a name and it
has a value and it allows you to put
data and think about it in a principled
way here's another variable this has a
different type it's a double has a
different name and it has a different
value
there's a whole bunch of different types
that you can have of variables and
they're a very practical idea the one
thing you don't see so explicitly in
code that maybe would be really nice
would be just saying I have a variable
and it can take on just exactly one of
these values
probability has an analogy to a
programming variable but it's slightly
different in that we're going to be
thinking about variables they're going
to take on values we just don't know
what value is going to take on yet and
we think about there being some
uncertainty as the value it takes on
so for example you can have an integer
and that integer could be like the
number of pirate ships in our future
Armada I was like going through a pirate
thing when I wrote this slide just
forgive all the pirate examples and you
can say I have a random variable it's
going to take on the values 1 2 we're
definitely going to have at least one
vote one two up to ten and it will be a
value it will take on a number we just
don't know at this point exactly what
that number is and we think there's some
Randomness that governs that number
similarly you can say the amount of
money we get after we defeat Blackbeard
that's going to be maybe a double or you
know continuous number and in
probability we would name that as a
random variable it's not a regular
variable because we don't yet know how
much money we're going to get and we
think that there's maybe some
probability distribution over all the
values you could get and then you know
probability random variables can also
have the variable type of something like
a true or false there's this idea of
Okay C is going to be one if you
successfully raid Ila de muerta and zero
otherwise and then you can say C it's a
variable it will take on the value 0 or
1. we just don't know yet if it will
take on zero or one we think there's
some uncertainty so so it's just going
to be new terminology for something that
we already for formulas that we've
already seen
so random variable variable it's going
to have a value and there's just
uncertainty as to what that value is
more examples if I say I have three or I
flip a coin three times
I could Define a random variable to be
the number of heads on the three coin
flips
Y is a random variable will it take on a
number
yeah eventually after I flip the coins
do we know which number it'll take on no
not yet we do know it's going to be
either zero one two or three
and there's a probability that it takes
on zero there's going to be a
probability that takes on One it
probably takes on two and it probably
takes on three so just like a random
variable there's just uncertainty as to
what value takes on
to be clear we could actually count that
probably takes on different values we
can say what's the probability that it's
zero well that means you got a Tails
tail sales
what's the probability that you get a
one so that y random variable could take
on the value of zero it could take on
the value one that means you got one
heads which is means you either gotten
the first flip the second Flip or the
third flip you could get two heads which
means you need head Tails or head Tails
Tails or tails head head or you could
even get three heads and there's a one
out of eight chance of that
so random variable is just going to be a
new name for a variable for whom we
don't know its value yet
the probability that it takes on some
number greater than four is zero you can
talk about the probability that takes on
a negative number but that's also zero
we think of it only as having
non-negative probabilities for zero one
two and three
I think there's just one confusing thing
that I'd like you guys to separate I've
just introduced you to this world of
random variables it's going to be a nice
happy world but the thing I want you to
distinguish and contrast it against is
the world of events because random
variables and events are different
things
um
okay and we'll just keep that contrast
in your mind
now on Wednesday's class we talked about
what happens if your coin doesn't come
up with equal likelihood of being heads
or tails so if you say you have five
coin flips each is independently coming
up heads with a probability of P you
know from Wednesday's class we figured
out that this is going to be five choose
two so choose all the ways that you can
put your two heads and then the outcome
of each of those events is going to be
the head probably the heads squared
because there's two of them and the
probability of Tails cubed because
there's three of them if
you don't remember how we got there
there's that wonderful example in the
course reader and it's certainly worth
revisiting until you feel comfortable
with the probability of exactly two
heads when your coin isn't 50 50.
um so if your wise number of heads on
five coin flips and P is the probability
of getting a heads then you can get a
probability function that looks a little
bit like this
okay
what are the three things the three most
important things you can say about a
random variable is somebody can give you
a function somebody a very kind soul
might tell you here's the probability of
every outcome of a random variable and
on some level this is one of the main
functions of a random variable a main
function of a random variable is
somebody can give you a whole bunch of
probabilities at once they can maybe
tell you the probability of any
assignment to the random variable we
call that the probability Mass function
when you have a random variable you can
also calculate these statistics that
you've probably heard about before like
expectation and variance but we need to
have this idea of a random variable
before we can do those and our learning
goals for today is really to master
these first two steps
so let's jump into it let's talk about
this probability Mass function
the relationship between the random
variables values they can take on and
the chance of it occurring is a function
let me convince you of this
here is a random variable for example
this random variable could be the number
of heads in five coin flips
this is an event and actually I'm going
to go back and forth between these two
one more time because I want you to see
the difference
this is a random variable it's the
number of outcomes on five coin flips
it's not an event
but if you say
the number of outcomes heads on Five
Point flips is two that's an event in
fact any Boolean operation you do with a
random variable will make an event like
if I say Y is less than 2
that's an event the number of out heads
being less than two that's an event but
the number of outcomes on five coin
flips it's not an event it's more like
an experiment
so maybe I want to pause here and take a
question so Random variables they're
variables that can take on values with
probabilities and they're different than
events you can go between them by asking
a Boolean question of your random
variable so that was the random variable
this is an event any questions about
this
events are always Boolean you made a
good observation every time probably
somebody talks about an event it's
either true or false it either happens
or it doesn't happen
that's a good observation yes
exactly the probability of a random
variable
yeah and that's a good question turns
out yes and probability of these things
are different than the events themselves
and you raise a good point you can ask
the probability of event but you can't
ask the probability of a random variable
on its own so it makes sense to ask
what's the probability that Y is less
than two
but it doesn't make sense to ask what's
the probability of Y
you can say what's the probability that
y equals zero you can say what's
probably y equals two you can say what's
the problem that Y is greater than 5 but
you can't say just probability of Y on
its own probabilities always want to be
over events that was a fantastic
question
okay
you guys ready to go up a notch so if y
equals 2 is an event
then if you put two in this is going to
be a probability a number between zero
and one are you guys falling I'm just
trying to construct this up slowly Y is
a random variable y equals 2 is an event
and then probably the Y equals 2 will be
a number between 0 and 1.
final idea
if you let this be a variable
what you now have is a function
if you put in different values for K you
should get out different probabilities
if you put in one you should get
probably that y equals one if you put in
two you should get probably the Y equals
two this is mathematically what we call
a function
you can think about functions in lots of
ways one way is you can think of it as
just being an input outreal relationship
you can put k equals 5 here and you
should get out of probability
you can also think about functions the
programming way you know if this is a
function you could write it up as code
and it could be a function and the
parameter is K if you pass in a 1 this
function should give you back the
probability that y equals one if you
pass in a two it should give you back
the probability that y equals two okay
you buy me with this function idea yes
just to be clear so Y is a random
variable in case just variable yeah
exactly that's a good good question why
is a random variable so we think about
taking on values with different
probabilities and K is just a like a
variable in programming that you can
just put in as a parameter and those are
two different concepts we use a lower
case for like the programming variable
concept and uppercase for the random
variable concept that's such a great
question
okay
so if a random variable is discrete and
by discrete I mean it takes on Integer
values or whole numbers uh we call this
function the probability Mass function
it's possibly the most important thing
to know for a random variable so if I
say of a random variable
the first thing you should wonder is
what's its probability Mass function
what's the relationship between all the
values it could take on and the
probabilities there's some shorthands
for it some people write this some
people write this in cs109 I'll almost
always try and write the full event out
you know this feels a little bit
redundant you've got what's the
probability that this random variable
takes on the value of this programming
variable and then some people are like
well because they're both called X I
could just skip the random variable and
just write this shorthand you might see
that in the probability paper
now
let me show you some probability Mass
functions again since they're functions
I can represent them as code I can
represent them as equations I can also
represent them as just drawings right I
can give you a graph that gives a
relationship between all the inputs of
the function and the outputs
here is a probably Mass function for
rolling a single dice what are all the
different outcomes of rolling a single
dice you could get a one you get two you
get a three you get a four you get five
you get a six and this most important
definition the relationship between
those numbers and their probabilities is
called the probability Mass function and
in this case all of those inputs lead to
a probability of 1 6. if you roll a dice
and X is the outcome of your dice you
probably have X taking on any value is
going to be 1 6. not the most exciting
example but I'm really just trying to
get you into this new terminology that
we're going to build on as we go towards
artificial intelligence
let's do something a little bit more
exciting let's say x is the sum of two
dice rolls
we've talked a lot about two dice rolls
right we've talked about how you could
calculate the probably the two dice
rolls is equal to two or three or four
the probability Mass function is going
to put all that information into one
place
so you don't have to individually
calculate the probably the two dice roll
is a seven you could just go to the
probably Mass function and look it up
and know that for 7 is going to be 6
over 36.
the probability Mass function could be
given to you like this it could also be
given to you like that
any way you could Define a function
programming math a graph all those are
valid ways of giving somebody the
relationship between the values a random
variable can take on and the
probabilities
I'll pause here for a second because
that's kind of cool also you're like
whoa that looks like a triangle awesome
yes question what about like when the
random variable isn't discrete like with
the blackbeards um yeah we will get to
non-discreet in about a week but for now
we're just being the happy world where
random variables are discrete which
means all their values uh are whole
numbers
okay fantastic does this I'm I hope I've
put enough energy into explaining this
that you're like this feels kind of
obvious
knowing
that's the I guess the original
probability of rolling a seven would
yeah it's a good point it's giving it to
all like imagine somebody gave you this
programming function
it's just somebody's done the work for
you it's like if I've done the work of
figuring out the probability of all
these different assignments to X
probably you can think of probably Mass
functions away from me encapsulate that
work and hand it over to another person
so it's allowing you to know that the
probability of two dice roll being seven
is six over 36 without having to do that
work
and you can imagine this will be nicer
later when we when we derive really
complicated probabilities it'll be nice
to be able to put them into packages and
then use them later on say your midterm
so your midterm you want to use a really
complicated process but you're like oh
earlier in class we derived it we put
into a random variable I can just refer
to that random variable and directly use
this probably Mass function so it's
going to allow us to build off the work
of others
help
good good good
fantastic question
okay
I do want to make you think about
something
imagine those two dice rolls I'm going
to sum over all values okay so 2 3 4 5 6
K are all the outcomes of the sum of two
dice if I sum over each of those and add
the probably that y takes on a
particular value what is this sum going
to come to talk to the person next to
you because this is important this is
fine check to make sure that you guys
are following along and to push you also
to think about what this means
okay
if you didn't get this this is fine but
it certainly an important thing to know
I'm asking take this probability add it
to this probability added to this
probability add to this probably sum
over all the K's look up the
probabilities and add those all together
and my question is what is that sum
going to be did anyone come up with an
idea
yes foreign
yeah I'm kind of asking what's the
probability of the sample space and that
was one of the axons of probabilities
because this is like the probability of
or you're adding so it's like talking
about the ore of these mutually
exclusive events are they mutually
exclusive can you get a sum of two and a
sum of three at the same time no they're
definitely mutually exclusive so this is
the or is it probably that y equals two
or y equals three or y equals four and
if you think about that or it's saying
what's the probability of any outcome
and the probability of any outcome
should be one so if you have a proper
random variable if you sum over all the
different inputs to the probability Mass
function you should get a one
okay
fantastic we have done one of those two
things that's it probably Mass functions
are simply somebody representing the
relationship between the value random
variable can take on and its probability
we now just need to learn this next
concept it turns out you have a random
variable
there's things you can do to summarize
that random variable and one of the
classic things is you can give somebody
an expectation
and expectation is something you've
probably heard called a lot of different
names you might have heard it called the
mean the weighted average the center of
mass the first moment
um most likely the mean and it's saying
if this is your random variable kind of
what's the most Central outcome here it
summarizes your whole random variable in
one statistic it's a lossy statistic but
it's one that a lot of people find
interesting
before we talk about how we can use it
let's talk about how it's defined it
says take your random variable let's
Loop over all the values that can take
on Little X and talk about the
probability that x equals Little X
so you know if I had to write this in
our notation
I would make this probability that
random variable X
on the value Little X and what you saw
in the slides is just shorthand for this
because people get bored of writing X's
so much
it says take on for every value take on
the value the probability that would
take on that value but we're going to
multiply it by the value itself
so it's saying you know it can take on a
one with this value a 2 with this value
and we're going to take one times its
probability add it to two times it's
probably and add to three times its
probability and that gives us the number
that some people find meaningful
let's just start with our favorite good
old friends when we're trying to
understand a concept dice
here's my dice it was a boring random
variable X is the boring random variable
that's the outcome of the dice but we
can start asking this question what's
the expectation of x
the probability that x equals one is the
same as probably that equals two the
same as probably that equals six all of
those outcomes are 1 6. the probably
Mass function was pretty straightforward
if we want to calculate the expectation
that's that statistic we can calculate
our random variable we'd say take one
multiply it by its probability add that
to 2 multiplied by its value probability
add that to three multiply by is
probability four multiplied by its
probability and up to six multiplied by
its probability if there's other
outcomes you would include them
if you do all of this you don't get a
function you get a number an expectation
will always give you a number and this
came it gave us 3.5
is 3.5 the most likely outcome of
rolling a dice
like what no you can't roll a 3.5 on
dice you can roll a three you can run
all four
um but you can imagine this is kind of
like the center outcome like the most
Central outcome it's the average between
three and four it's the value that's
closest to each of the outcomes weighted
by their probabilities so if one of
these was really really likely it would
pull this number closer to one if seven
was really really or six was really
really likely it would pull the outcome
closer to six so it's just a weighted
average of the outcomes
practice let's say Y is a random
variable it can take on three values one
two or three if somebody asks you count
the expectation can you do this even if
I haven't told you anything more about
the random variable like what it
semantically means if I just gave you
the probability Mass function written
out as three statements can you figure
out the expectation
absolutely just take each of those
outcomes and multiply it by its
probability so this is what expectation
looks like in a slightly more General
case
okay
make fun with this there's three kinds
of lies lies down lies and statistics so
when you summarize a random variable by
one number you lose a lot of information
people use this to manipulate other
people let me give you an example
universities
they try and make it sound like all
their classes are super small and this
is how they do it
every University reports its average
class size
but what they report to you is they
report the expectation of class side if
you were to choose a random class
imagine a school with three classes one
class is five students one class is ten
students and one class has 150 students
to calculate the statistic that
universities report they imagine this
thing they say randomly choose a class
with equal probability X is the size of
the chosen class what is the expectation
of x
and to calculate this they say well
there's three outcomes of this the size
of X it could be 5 10 or 150 the chances
five is one-third
because there's a one-third chance you
got that class the chance of 10 is one
third and a chance of 150 is one-third
and even though this class has or this
university has a class of 150 students
and most people are probably going to be
in that one they report that their
average class size is only 55.
convenient
okay let's be a little bit more cheeky
let's say you randomly choose a student
with equal probability and now I want to
know why is the size of the class that
the students in
this gives you a totally different
number and actually just let's think
about it for a second we don't have to
talk about Interest next to you but like
think about how you would calculate this
what's the expectation of why now the
first thing you should ask yourself or
what are the values that y can take on
and it turns out y can stay still only
take on the values 5 10 or 150. if you
randomly pick a student and assuming
they're only in one of those three
classes
you know they could be in the class of
size five they can be in a class of size
10 they can be in class of size 150. but
what's the probability of each of those
outcomes
the probability that you pick the
student that's in the class of size five
is five divided by the number of
students in this University 165. each
person is only in one class
the chance that you chose a student
who's in the class of size 10 is 10 over
165 and the chance that you chose the
person who's in the class of 150 is 150
by 165. so if you ask this question you
know what's the expectation of the size
of a class of a randomly chosen student
now is 137.
expectations are a powerful tool one of
the reasons that they're powerful is
they have these very very amazing
properties but I do also want you to
know that a lot of people give you
misleading information using expectation
expectation summarizes a whole random
variable in one number
if I want a random variable given to me
I want somebody give me the whole
probably Mass function tell me the
probability of each of your outcomes
that's what I really care about I don't
just want a number that summarizes into
one value so the probability Mass
function full information expectation
dumbs it down into one number
now that one number is very useful to
computer scientists though because it
has some amazing properties it turns out
if you do a lot of Transformations or
weird manipulations to a random variable
like maybe X is the number of heads on a
coin flip but you're playing a game
where you're going to take that multiply
it by number and add another number to
get the amount of profit you have
if you want to know the expectation of
your profit it turns out you could
calculate it just by knowing the
expectation of the underlying random
variable of number of heads on your coin
flips
so if you take any linear transformation
of a random variable multiply it by a
normal variable add in another normal
variable you would still get something
that you could calculate without doing
too much extra math
uh
this is another amazing one now here I
was adding a random variable to a
non-random variable so just like a
constant but it turns out if you have
two random variables and you want to
talk about the sum of those two random
variables no matter if they're
independent or not no matter if they're
mutually exclusive or not the
expectation of the sum of random
variables is always the sum of the
expectations this is amazing so if I say
this is the number of heads I get if I
flip 10 coins and this is the number of
sixes I get if I roll two dice and if I
want to talk about you know the sum of
those two numbers
the expectation of the sum of the
numbers is equal to the expectation of
the number of heads on my 10 flips plus
the number of sixes on my 10 dice rolls
so if you want to do the expectation of
sums you have a very nice decomposition
doesn't matter if they're independent or
whatnot
and this is something we'll use in
proofs I'm going to talk about a lot
more once we use it but I'm just going
to list it now we'll talk about it later
okay so that's it we have probably Mass
functions we have expectations that's
what I wanted you guys to be comfortable
with in terms of random variables going
out of today's class
wonderful in that case it's time to play
a little game
we're going to play a game and it's
going to involve random variables and
expectations and it's a classic game
that's kind of interesting to think
about
let me give you the setup I have a fair
coin I got this thing off the internet
but I flipped it a whole bunch I'm
pretty sure it's fair by fair I mean
it's equally likely to be heads or tails
it's not one of those frisbee things
I'm going to flip this coin until it
comes up heads
all right sorry let me see
sorry I'm going to flip this coin until
it comes up Tails so maybe I get a heads
I flip it again I get a heads I flip it
again I get a heads I flip it again I
get tails the game is over
we're gonna say n is the number of coin
flips before my first Tales so it's how
many times I flip the coin
um and then I'm going to win 2 to the
power of n dollars
my question for you is how much would
you pay to play and just my hint is
people often ask answer this question by
thinking about your expected winnings
how much do you expect to win if you
played this game
and you would if the cost to play the
game is less than your expected winnings
you should probably pay it
so think about expectation in this
harder situation
random variable is how much you win
what are the different outcomes you
could win two to the one
you could win two to the squared you can
win two to the third but what's the
probability of each of those because you
have to weight each of those outcomes by
its probability add it up and then you
get your expected winnings
I'm gonna give you guys a second to
think about it I want you to answer the
question how much would you pay to play
and then we're actually going to play
talk to the person next to you make
friends
oh you guys want to know
okay
this is independent of the calculation
you got
is there anyone who would pay play this
game with me for a thousand dollars
in theory or in practice
okay okay no no I mean in practice like
you're gonna step up and we're gonna
play this for a thousand dollars
once
I've never had somebody take me up on it
I got a little sweaty there
but on in theory it was a good decision
right why was it such a good decision
because this really pushes the
definition of expectation to its limit
now I do want to clarify one thing I
think there's two ways of reading this
if you get like a tails on your first
flip do you get two to the power of one
dollars you get two to the power of zero
dollars depends how you think of before
so some people say this is going to be
the number of heads is how many is n and
some people think number of coin flips
is n it doesn't matter how you interpret
it they both lead to the same answer
okay solution
Define a random variable just like we
used to define events we're going to now
get used to defining random variables if
somebody asks you an expectation
question the first thing you should do
is Define the random variable that
they're asking you the expectation over
so X is your winnings
this is the version where if you get a
tail on your first coin flip you win two
to the zero dollars
if you get a heads than a tail you win
two to the first sorry heads and tails
you get you win two dollars if you get
heads Heads Tails You Win two squared
dollars you get heads Heads head sales
you get two to the Third
now what's the probability of getting a
tails on your first coin flip that's one
half what's the chance of getting a
heads than a tails one half times
one-half
what's the chance of getting heads Heads
Tails one half to the third heads heads
Heads tails you guys get the point
and you see this nice little pattern I
could write this formula into this
beautiful little equation I could say
it's the sum from zero to Infinity
of one-half to the power of I plus one
times two to the power of I
and that's just taking it's like oh this
this term has I and I plus one and this
one has I and I plus one
and if you work this out I guess it
really is important that well okay you
would get even more money if I gave you
the extra two dollars for the heads
in this case it's going to be
or how can we reduce this you know 2 to
the I divide by 2 to the I Plus 1.
is just going to be equal to 1 over 2.
and now that whole term becomes the sum
from 0 to Infinity of one-half
and that's Infinity
your theoretical winnings of this game
is infinite because even though it might
not be that likely that you win ten
thousand dollars there's also chance
that you win like 10 trillion dollars or
like 20 trillion dollars or like a
gazillion infinite dollars and this
totally breaks this idea of expectation
maybe it's another way to talk about how
expectation isn't always the best
summary of a random variable
but then I offer people this choice I
say will you play this for a thousand
dollars and I've been teaching 109 for a
while and this is the closest we've ever
gotten to somebody taking me up on it
and it's because even though in theory
your expected wings are Infinity it
feels too risky and I have a very
concrete way of articulating the risk
Chris doesn't have infinite dollars if
you play this game
but you win 65 536 you know what happens
I don't stay here and pay you I split I
just run I just leave the country you
never see me you never get your winnings
so really like if you won ten thousand
dollars I might be like okay fair game
and if you win twenty thousand dollars
I'd be like fair game but you win enough
money and you're never ever seeing me
and you should take this into account
when you think about whether or not you
want to play this game so same equation
that's your chance of winning to uh one
dollar this is your chance of winning
two dollars transfer winning three
dollars in the same equation it's just
that this doesn't go from zero to
Infinity it's just going to go up to how
many heads lead to sixty five thousand
dollars and the answer to that is 16.
like if you're up here getting 15 14
heads I'm like okay 15 heads I'm booking
my flight 16 heads I'm gone
and if you add one half to itself 16
times you are not very close to Infinity
you are eight point five dollars so I
would say that this game is worth about
eight point five dollars to play
not infinite what a way to think about
expectations I know I've pushed the idea
of expectation pretty hard but hopefully
that gives you a solid understanding of
expectation going into the weekend and
hope you feel about good about the
learning goals and I hope you guys have
a great weekend enjoy you've worked very
hard see you back on class on Monday